I get in shut the door dude immediately
makes a wrong turn out of the parking
lot and I am on his ass I'm like oh
no we know where we're going
we know where we're going and he starts
stuttering he gets nervous he's like I
uh
I know it's shortcut don't worry I'm
gonna get you there in a jiffy and I
said jiffy
nobody says Jiffy anymore
this son of a [__] is gonna kill us
listen that's right where my mind goes
all right you can judge me all you want
to but I live my life like every gun is
loaded okay every snake is a king cobra
and no matter what touches me in the
ocean it's Jaws okay I know I've had
seaweed hit me in the leg and I'm like
I'm trying to ever try to walk something
off in the ocean you can't look cool
doing that
can't
the Honeydew with Brian sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan's sick on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
thank you for your support this channel
has grown the community has grown the
special continues to do well please go
watch and support my special Lefty son
on my YouTube channel and uh while
you're there subscribe to that channel
alright and if you gotta have more then
you gotta check out the patreon it's
called the Honeydew of y'all and it's
thought he do with y'all and like I say
every week the wildest [__]
stories on the internet I don't care
what else you got out there it's five
bucks a month you're getting the
Honeydew ad free you're getting it a day
early you're getting it audio and video
alright at no additional cost it's five
bucks and you still have hundreds of
episodes to go and listen into so go
check it out it's definitely worth your
time and if you're looking for a new
podcast go check out an old favor called
The Crab Feast it's an audio only one
subscribe it's a great storytelling
podcast I used to do with Jay Larson and
uh the tour starting guys I'm starting
to feel better enough to get out there
they tell me my my D dimer levels look
like they're in the right zones to
travel so may 26th and 27th the live and
the live tour kicks off in Fort Wayne
Indiana uh June 23rd and 24th I'll be in
Tacoma Washington July 7th and 8th
Appleton Wisconsin we did have to
reschedule Tulsa Oklahoma July 21st and
22nd because the club's not going to be
ready yet not because of your boy your
boy's kinda ready I was gonna say I stay
ready but I'm kind of ready all right
now you all know what we do over here by
the way dates are continuing to be added
all tickets available at Ryan
sickler.com that's the biz you know what
we're doing over here we're highlighting
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers very
excited to have this guest on here today
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Dave
Stone welcome to the Honeydew day thank
you buddy thank you brother thanks for
having me you're welcome man thank you
for being here and uh before we get into
your story today why don't you plug and
promote everything Dave Stone sure uh
got a new special out now on YouTube uh
called pack a lunch uh so you can go
watch that right now also you can get
the uh audio version on vinyl at
blondmedicine.com that's who I'm my
album's with yeah great fun great folks
Dominic and uh Jessica yeah great folks
over there so yeah uh limited edition
vinyl it's a big fat two LP I'm a vinyl
guy so I I like the colored vinyl so we
got like a nice colored variant uh two
LP uh limited edition they're moving
quick so get over there
blindmedicine.com and grab those and
then uh two podcasts I do the boogie
monster with Kyle Kinane uh up and
coming young lad I think he's gonna do
all right great episode here on honey
dude
uh yeah boogie monster and then I do
another podcast called the stonebergs
with my wife where uh a really um
disheveled married couple tries to give
advice to people and all right so yeah
two idiots that can barely handle their
own business or trying to uh lend Our
advice to to the masses so that's where
you can find me all right well I know
you have we have a specific story to
talk about today but let's lead up into
that so you're originally from Georgia
correct yep Georgia all right you grow
up there and
um well how do you get into what do you
get into work wise as soon as you're out
of school are you going to college first
what is what is Dave Stone doing yeah I
went to college uh walked on at West
Georgia University football did you yeah
what position uh Lineback the old
linebacker slash kicker combo
this guy's a good kicker maybe we can
put him at uh we climbacher uh just did
that for a couple of months till I hurt
my knee and then uh knew that I was
gonna miss like the whole season walked
on and walked off yep walked on and
walked off yeah limped off yeah so uh
and then just went uh like a community
college for like another couple of
semesters just no idea what I wanted to
do uh dropped out of that and went to
broadcasting school so my first like
career job I was a radio DJ in Atlanta
for about four years what radio station
uh a bunch of them but the big one it
was the one that I grew up listening to
so that's pretty cool in Atlanta 99x
wnnx was like the K-Rock of Atlanta you
know modern rock or alt Rock whatever
you want to call it but uh yeah so it's
doing that and uh and at the same time
bouncing around at other radio stations
like uh it was such a nomadic profession
I literally moved eight times in four
years and then my final radio job uh I
got let go because it was right when it
was right around the turn of the century
that sounds weird to say but when
everything was becoming automated and
there was a lot of consolidation and
just like half our station got laid off
and uh that's what led to my other
career that we'll talk about later but
uh yeah radio
um did some odds and ends uh this is
some people find this interesting I was
actually a tour manager for a couple of
metal bands were you really yeah uh
Chris Jericho's band Fozzie they're
still around are they they're still out
there doing it playing good sized venues
but yeah it was Fozzy and stuck Mojo's
tour manager for a couple of years stuck
Mojo's one of these old like uh rap
metal Pioneers early 90s so yeah this is
the same core Anthrax and [__] about the
same time yeah so it was the same core
group of dudes they had stuck Mojo uh
the same core and then Fozzie was
basically the same band but ad Jericho
on vocals so okay that was cool and you
know I grew up a wrestling guy I kind of
I'm not a wrestling guy anymore I mean I
I appreciate that 40 year old men are
obsessed with it but uh I uh I grew out
of it but it was still cool like you
know working with Jericho and that was
like kind of the peak of his Fame so uh
we got to go do some of those wrestling
shows Monday Night Raw went up there in
the band performed live and uh got to
meet Stone Cold and The Rock before he
was just a mega star but uh yeah so a
little bit of everything so then you're
bouncing around doing this and that then
how do you get into
your career in its law is it law
enforcement yeah I was I was just a cop
I was just a uniform Beat cop what made
you decide to do that uh I just needed a
job like when radio ended I was just
kind of bouncing around doing part-time
jobs and during that time I got engaged
way too young and I'm 23 I'm engaged I
I'm done with my radio career uh you
know I got no education to fall back on
I was like ah I just needed
health insurance and a 401k and uh a
buddy of mine had already worked for
this Police Department he's like hey
we're hiring next year man you need to
apply and I was like I don't know if I
want to be a cop
and uh one thing led to another how old
are you at that point I started when I
was 23. okay and were you always a guy
that you could pass a piss test and all
that stuff or did you also have to go
clean and sober to become a cop no back
then I was straight edge like I wasn't
like straight edge but I just I didn't
drink I didn't smoke so that wasn't the
problem that wasn't an issue okay so
what is the what is it like what is are
you and are you in Atlanta like PD or
what is what are you a Georgia Trooper
like what the hell are you I was Cobb
County Police in Cobb County is uh most
of Atlanta is in Fulton County but the
county just north of there which I think
technically some of Atlanta seeps into
was Cobb County so it was County Police
uh big department I think we had like
close to a thousand officers
um you know just North Metro Atlanta was
our whole area so yeah just uh went to
the academy that was about uh eight or
nine months and then wait it's that long
yeah yeah it was it was quite that's
longer than boot camp then oh yeah yeah
yeah something like that but yeah this
was I think eight months and what are
you learning just it was classroom
setting Monday through Friday uh just I
I I'm tempted to do my my jokes but uh
just they teach you the basics of law
enforcement like a lot half of it was
like like law school kinda you know they
teach you the the textbook stuff and
then the other half was more you know
Hands-On tactical stuff now how are you
learning situations like we're seeing on
[__] everybody's cell phone from a
classroom
like
learning mistakes from real officers or
just I mean how do you teach how do you
teach a cop that's under duress
that same feeling and [__] in a
classroom you can't well they show you a
lot of videos oh you do every video of
every cop who ever got his ass kicked
we're gonna show you this video I
haven't seen the one where the guy got
killed and they were saying what he did
wrong yeah and you can hear him
screaming and [__] yeah yeah they really
Hammer that into your head and like
they're showing you brothers and sisters
that are dying because of mistakes they
made yeah that's part of the training
yeah and uh the term for it they call
officer safety like they just hammered
officer safety and like
you know I have as we'll learn I have
mixed emotions about my time there but
uh I will say it was a good Department
in terms of like training you know it
wasn't you know Mayberry sure it was a
big department well-funded a lot of
resources a lot of good training so they
they really Hammer officer safety so you
get out of
uh training and what do you become then
what is your first job first job is just
uh with just uniform Patrol basically is
it in a car do they still have on foot
patrol anymore I don't think so maybe
some cities that have you know a a real
pedestrian heavy you know City Center
might but I don't think we had any uh on
foot cops we had bicycle cops and stuff
like that but uh basically everybody
starts out in uh what we call uniform
Patrol and our whole uh department or
territory was divided up into five
different precincts and then within each
Precinct you have Beats but so they send
you to one of the five precincts and uh
for another eight months you ride with
an fto a field training officer so it's
like eight or nine months of schooling
then you get out and then you just ride
shotgun every night for about another
eight months so my [__] cousin this
[__] lucked out I mean Diddy or
ditney I think he did but same thing he
gets out of uh is it what is it called
we call it mandate School mandate school
and now he's riding with a partner or
whatever and it is week one it might be
day two and they all of a sudden they're
in a high speed chase yeah and they're
chasing this car and some [__] cuts
out in front of them so the his partner
tries to go around them and in doing so
he hits the median and the car flips and
they're rolling and they're both okay
cars upside down my cousin's ankles
[__] and he's climbing out and he said
Ryan I was so
[__] up and concussed and disoriented
that he just said they teach you also to
cover your weapon and that's all that
kept going through his head was protect
my [__] weapon so someone doesn't get
it and use it against me and he said he
couldn't help it but all he kept he said
no one was asking him anything and he
just kept yelling I am the police I am
the police and he said no one was asking
him okay they're like we know you're
awesome
he said I am the police oh I was
laughing so hard so they put rods and
[__] in his [__] uh ankle and he gets
married and he's doing his little vows
and he cries you know and he's Mr
Italian-American hard ass doesn't cry he
cries and I'm [__] with him a little
bit I'm like oh you're over there crying
[__] you [__] we get to the
reception and there's this [__] step
down that it is hard as [__] to see
uh-huh uh-oh and he hits this
[__] step down and that ankle
pops and he goes down the crowd and he's
holding it he just looks up at me and A
Tear comes down his face and I just had
I couldn't help it I had to kick him
eyes now I was like Hey Tiffy cried
twice in his wedding everybody look at
this [__] it's okay he's the
police
I should have yelled yeah I thought he
was gonna yell that I am the police this
[__] yeah yeah dude so he then
gets like they give him an office job
and now he's a liability on the streets
because of what happened yeah they
[__] retire him after only a few
years really and his early 30s and he
gets a full pension and everything the
rest of his life and they do programs
where like if you move into a
neighborhood they'll give you a discount
on the house because they want you to
have you know a little presence in the
neighborhood you know especially if your
Trooper takes a car home yeah that
[__] cruiser sitting in the driveway
is like let's not go [__] with that guys
yes you know yeah yeah I had a couple of
those gigs where I got free rent at an
apartment complex in exchange for being
the um what do they call courtesy
officer who's the courtesy officer I'd
handle noise complaints and stuff like
that or if I was actually working in
something they'd call me and I'd just
send somebody else over there but yeah
yeah you just I think we call those part
times there's all kind of little part
times so you can do to supplement your
income okay yeah but that was a that was
a sweet gig just working at a just
living free rent in a nice apartment
complex yeah and I'd once a month I'd
have to hand out notices or you know the
occasional noise complaint but yeah it
was pretty easy pretty good game so when
do you grow up through uh come up
through the ranks a bit or what uh not
really I wasn't there long enough
to really climb the ranks I was there
about four years four and a half years
okay
um so yeah and uh hated every second of
it did you yeah you know at first
because like I said it wasn't anything I
didn't grow up wanting to be a cop sure
you know it's not in your family yeah it
wasn't my family but you know I still
had obviously an interest in it in terms
of like well if I gotta have a job you
know at least I'm not sitting behind a
desk and you got to remember too the
climate wasn't what it is now this was
uh 22 years ago this is when everybody
was getting away with what's going on
now
but also just the general climate wasn't
and no it wasn't you know paranoid as it
is now just because there's not that
that stuff didn't go on back then but it
just wasn't on the news every night like
it is now so
um but yeah my point is
you know I thought okay well I need a
job I need like a real job something
where I can get some health benefits and
stuff so like for a guy who doesn't have
a college degree you know this might be
about the best I can do at this point in
time
23 years old yeah so um you know I went
into it with a good attitude but then it
just it just sucks the life out of you
quick because you just
and I'm in a weird position now where I
see both sides of it you know I'm
definitely not pro police but I'm you
know I see both sides and I'm quick to
when I see a cop doing something wrong
in the news I'm like yeah [__] that guy
he should have known better but also
when some homeowners association
president screaming because a cop did
something wrong like well you don't know
exactly what their job entails so pump
the brakes a little bit but uh you just
every night you see
what's the craziest [__] you you saw in
your four years third day out on the
street that this I won't do the bit but
I have this I close in my new special
about third night out of the academy out
on the street with an fto we find a I
found a
decapitated head come on dude just yep
guy uh what do you mean you found it guy
uh 19 year old Georgia Tech Student
committed suicide by laying his head
across some train tracks and you guys
are just out there cruising around and
you look over and see ahead or you got a
call we got a call that there's a
mannequin on some train tracks oh no and
we both were like I think I literally
even said like that's an odd reason to
call the police and we get there and uh
not a mannequin just uh
real human body with no head and I found
where was the head how far away about 10
yards
ditch it cut it off and rolled his head
rolled yeah I Wonder Don't You Wonder
Don't You wonder if for like 10 seconds
the brain is working enough where his
head's bouncing he's seeing that [__] go
around I mean and then the camera just
got to be a little bit there's no way
it's instant there's no way it's instant
if you're I don't know the inside I
don't know a lot of anything the inside
joke was how many trains came by before
he actually went through with it another
fun fact zero blood they just cauterized
the one did it yeah because all the heat
from them they're not Wheels but what
are the things the train you know the
little circular metal I guess yeah
and uh again not gonna do the whole bit
but in my bit and it's all true
eventually my fto hands me a trash bag
no and says quote go get him Stone no
and I was like do what
and then I was I mean he got shitty
about it he's like take this [__] bag
go get his head I was like oh
okay day three day three you picked up a
human head mm-hmm yeah day three good
times on the job listen there's cops out
there that have been on the force 30
years ago they can't tell you they've
done that day two the night before that
day two I stepped in a bucket of human
[__] yeah that happens us outside here
at the studios walking through a crack
house five gallon Home Depot paint
bucket no yeah five gallon how do you
step in a five gallon bucket it's dark
we were just kind of feeling around do
high stepping and yeah it's just yeah
for that reason because I knew I was
gonna step on something just right now I
was like oh that was squishy oh that's
fancy too I love being a cop and day
three is a head Severance yeah it's uh
yeah you just you see the worst of
humanity oh yeah a lot of fights tell me
about some fights uh I thought a guy
who's trying to take my gun
yeah I mean seriously in four years
probably
12 or 15. that's [__] that's every
three months yeah yeah just a [__]
kicker that's cool
because that's what people understand
like
if you and I had an encounter with the
police like
it would be a big deal in our week or
our month or in our year but I'm
fighting people that I'm probably the
third cop they fought this month
it's just like this is what I do I'm not
afraid to fight a [__] cop send me to
jail at least I don't have to pay rent
like that was the mentality of some of
these people like they just there's
nothing scarier than someone who has
nothing to lose amen and you're just
dealing with people who have nothing to
lose what the [__] do I care right you
know and it was such an eye tell me
about some of the fights you said a guy
was trying to get your gun yeah yeah
well this is the whole story that we're
leading up to was just it was a series
of events that just left me so
disgruntled you know it was just just a
disgruntled officer I kind of fight one
time with a dude literally trying to
steal my gun
knocked upon it not to steal it and run
into the woods try to take my gun so he
could use it on me uh we're you know
it's [__] got his hands all over my
why what is like what do you fight would
you catch up with him for he had a
warrant he's going to jail it's when
people know they're going to jail [__]
that no I'm not and they're not these
guys know they're not going to jail for
this charge they're going to jail
because they got a warrant from an old
charge that is now going to give them
five years ten years in prison whatever
it may be and when you're dealing with
people that are like oh if this cop puts
both handcuffs on me I'm going to jail
for 10 years or whatever the case may be
and it was one of those situations where
my it was with I was with another
officer one little technique and they
always get this wrong in the movies if
if you're a perp and I'm a cop and I
know I run your license there's a
warrant pops up I don't tell you that
you're under arrest until I have
handcuffs on you if I go hey turn around
you're under arrest
so you're like well I could run or I
could fight or whatever you always
there's a technique to trick I'm like
hey man before we go any further uh let
me you mind if I pat you down just to
make sure you don't have any bombs or
Bazookas on you and usually they'll
comply to that and you get them to turn
around like just put your hands behind
your back and you Pat them down click
click you want to put those cuffs on
them when they don't realize it's coming
that's legal yeah oh yeah absolutely
absolutely so even if they're not under
arrest even if you just need to detain
them for your own safety but yeah you
you act like you're just patting them
down hey turn around real quick click
click but if I go hey man you got a
warrant you're going to jail you're like
no I'm not so anyway in that scenario my
partner is the one that told him he was
going to jail before you Mr trigger
happy over here before no it's another
one but before we had handcuffs on it
and this guy just started swinging and
it was literally big dude big dude two
on one and he was you know we weren't
winning
he's trying to grab my uh
we weren't winning and the point is I
got one handcuff on him and we're still
fighting and uh I I to this day I don't
remember if it was my partner or me
because it was just such a melee but uh
he got his wrist broke he had one
handcuff on and his other wrist got
broke and I got in trouble for excessive
use of force while uh a suspect is in
custody because he had one handcuff on
and when you deal with stuff like this
uh I don't know how other departments do
it but we had like a civilian review
board and what that means is you have
people from the war you know an employee
from the water department an employee
from the solicitor's office an employee
from the fire it's a it's a civilian
they're they're not technically
civilians because they work for the
county I see but it's a civilian review
board and you I have to go and explain
what happened
to people who have never been in law
enforcement or in that scenario this guy
works for the water department and he's
judging how I did my job and I got
suspended for excessive use of force
because I we broke a guy's wrist who was
in handcuffs and I was also trying to
get your gun to kill exactly and I kept
saying handcuff singular yeah singular
we had one on him and he was trying to
get my gun and so it was a series of
things like that that just led me to
being like [__] this job [__] this
department and you know we can get into
that later but yeah that's what I want
to talk about that led up to what take
us there my poor decision making have
you ever been just too damn High we've
all been there with today's weed finding
your perfect dose can be a dangerous
game dad grass is Reviving the pleasure
of the Casual toke so you can chill out
without the stress that grass is legal
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints and flour are
very low in THC and high in CBD so you
can enjoy the effects of CBD while
keeping a clear head not looking to talk
digress also offers the finest tinctures
and gummies on the market all the Mellow
goodness no smoke required all dag grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it chips right to your door
anywhere in the U.S whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite that grass will
leave you any euphoria mood right now
dagrass is offering my listeners 20 off
your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for twenty percent off your
first order that's daggrass.com honeydew
now let's get back to the Duke what was
poor what was poor decision making well
like I said this was just this was a
series of things like that I got
suspended another time for wrecking a
car in a Chase and it's like I'm chasing
a guy
I wasn't on my way to work in a police
car and just drag racing you know like
just getting not that like of course
there has to be checks and balances but
the whole problem at least back then
they
like I said in the academy every day we
watched a video of a cop getting killed
you know officer safety officer safety
officer safety but also you gotta do
every single [__] thing exactly right
or we're gonna suspend you or fire you
or sue you or whatever so you know you
ask these officers to go out and do
something you know dangerous but and I'm
not defending corruption like of course
you get but like
you're gonna suspend me because I broke
a dude's wrist who was only in one
handcuff a guy who was literally trying
to kill me like I said he didn't he
didn't want my gun because he's a
collector right he wanted to go run and
pawn it clean it she's gonna [__]
kill me yeah but yeah I get suspended a
week without pay because this guy got
his wrist broke and he had one handcuff
on so it's just that mentality or like
my department was very stat driven it
was like you know stats me how many
tickets you write tonight Stone how many
arrests did you make it's like oh I
didn't make any because I handled 14 911
calls you know I'm going to like
dangerous 911 calls and my beat Partners
writing speeding tickets so I would go
to dangerous calls with no backup
because why no backup because my we call
it beat Partners like I said the
precinct it was well the department was
divided into five precincts I worked at
zone three and then within that Precinct
we had like 13 beats it just mean little
territories you know Dave handled 31-11
handles this beat 31-12 handles that
beat and like uh you we didn't have
Partners in the car but we had beat
Partners meaning if I'm 31-12 and you're
31-11 well if 31-12 gets a call then as
soon as I you know 10-4 in route then my
beat partner goes in code we'll just say
show me in route to back him up any
almost any call we you'd have to go back
somebody up because we don't know what
it is right you know
and and it's we're we're responsible for
each other now if someone if if my beat
partner is writing a ticket
and someone else is available then they
might be like they'll give this guy a
chance to hop in and go I'm gonna code
seven what was the phrase but if no one
is going to back me up then someone else
can hop on and go hey I'll go back him
up but if they're all busy and my beat
Partners right in a [__] speeding
ticket and I'm going to an armed robbery
by myself so and then you get back to
the precinct they're like why didn't you
write any speeding tickets it was like
and we had this thing called a daily it
was just your you log everything I'm
like look at my [__] daily when was I
supposed to write a speeding ticket so
it's a lot of that like
where's your stats you know on paper it
looks like officer Stone didn't do [__]
tonight because he had no tickets and no
rest
but I went to 13 different [__] calls
you know like I have paperwork I have
reports on all these calls but anyway
I'm elaborating on that but it was just
that mentality of like do this but also
do this and don't do that but also do
this and why aren't you doing that and
make sure you do it yeah buy the book
yeah yeah and uh it was a series of just
disgruntled events and uh you almost
just get to the good part
one day
yeah this you know I told this story on
the boogie monster and uh
but yeah and I was telling you off the
air like uh I've been to a comedy 16
years I've just now started talking
about cop stuff just I kept it a secret
for all these years just because
hey the story I'm about to tell
but also just even if there was no
negative stories it's still like oh
you're a cop [__] this guy and like as
you know half of stand up is winning
over the audience or becoming likable
long story short
been a cop four and a half years
probably been suspended three or four
times without pay for things that I
thought were unjust I'm Wrecking a car I
got suspended for wrecking a car
because I was chasing a guy a guy
wouldn't pull over but I reckon just
[__] like that it's like what and then
you know the people handing out the
sentences or people that work at the
water department it's like lady do you
have any [__] idea what I do so
anyway I think I've made that point
clear I was very disgruntled this is not
reflection of my character
but uh one day pulled over this dude he
was a Latino guy like one of the
cheapest tickets we had he was like a
tag light the little that was the
easiest probable cause the little light
that illuminates your license plate most
everybody's has gone out yeah and
there's no way for you to know that
unless like your buddy yeah or your
buddy checks it who does like a full
inspection of all their lights or
whatever anyway easiest probable cause
in the world and I've I've got to
talking to because I'm not writing
enough tickets all right I'm gonna write
a bunch of [__] tag like tickets it's
the cheapest ticket here you go man
sorry it's 50 bucks 60 bucks pulled over
this one guy one night uh Latino fella
no English
and he was trying to you know show him
the ticket you turn around on the back
you Circle the phone number hey call
this number in 10 days they'll tell you
how much your fine is everybody's like
how much is it that's the question
everybody asked for the ticket we don't
like keep up with it but like we knew
that like this is one of the cheapest
tickets at the time it was like 50 60
bucks
and I was explaining this guy you know
no English and he pulls out a 50 bills
like I pay now and he wasn't trying I
don't think he was trying to bribe me
but he was literally just like
can I just pay now and I kept saying no
man call this phone number they'll tell
you where to mail the check blah blah
blah I pay now
I pay now no you don't pay now after
about the fifth time
sure man you can pay now
I took fifty dollars I didn't need the
fifty dollars it was a [__] you to the
department you know it's like I'm trying
to explain to this guy I fresh off a
suspension very disgruntled
sure man in in the interest of putting
this issue to bed and moving on with our
days yeah you can pay now
and then I took his ticket back so he
wouldn't like
and uh
six months go by
and the story that was later told to me
this is how I got caught
uh that guy whoever he was his brother
got a ticket a similar ticket one night
and his brother was complaining like I
got a [__] and then the guy I dealt
with like oh you could just why didn't
you just pay the officer and his
brother's like that's not how that works
and goes well that's how it worked for
me he's like what
he's like yeah I got pulled over I gave
the officer 50 bucks
and then they that this brother
complained to the police department and
they tracked they they figured out the
location and the time and my physical
description and uh they called me in and
you admitted it yeah why
just
trying to do the right thing you know I
was like well I mean I had I also want
to ask you this six months go by this
thing at this point probably it's had
you even remembered it or thought about
it I thought about it I thought it
because I knew it was wrong yeah I knew
that were you thinking about it like boy
six months down the line this could bite
me Nas I mean what a weird way for some
[__] to come back and get you get this
[__] okay unbeknownst to me
okay once this guy filed the complaint
and then they figured out figured out it
was me they did an internal
investigation they had collaborated with
the gbi the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation they thought I Was a
Serial offender they thought I was just
out there every night targeting latinos
with broken English who may or may not
even be here they thought because
apparently this had happened before
when it was all said and done and I'm in
handcuffs talking to the internal
affairs they they were just convinced
hold up you can't just jump the
handcuffs hold on they brought you in
did you get to go home that night or
that day you're going no I got
eventually I got to go home that night
so what happened they're talk what they
asked you straight up did you do this
and you say yes I did well and my point
too with the investigation get this
though uh they had undercover gbi
officers tailing me uh during my whole
shift and for how long and baiting me
for a couple of weeks baiting it I
remember this Happened One Night one
night it was a couple months after this
had happened uh I'm going to call uh I
see this one car multiple times
throughout the night the same car it was
like a gray Pontiac Grand Am
and like I'm going to a call and this
car like does something and I'm like boy
this fucker's lucky I gotta go to a 911
call or I totally stopped this [__]
like what's this guy doing and then I
saw him again a couple hours later he
threw trash out the window
and I was going to another call and I
saw him for the third time in the same
night doing something crazy and I
finally stopped him I was like dude did
you not see the police car I was like
I've seen you twice tonight you're lucky
that blah blah and it was a Latino guy
and he tried to bribe me he did and
fortunately for me in the back of my
mind I'm like well I know I did that
once but I ain't doing this [__] again
fortunately for me I was like no that's
not how this works blah blah blah I
wrote him a real ticket went on with his
day later when the investigation was
concluded they revealed that that was a
gbi officer who was trying to bait me it
was and he was on he had Camp body cams
and they were trying to get me to do it
again on camera
and like at the time I was like what
what an idiot what is this guy doing and
then I was like oh that's what that guy
was doing that's a gbi officer
undercover trying to bait me see if
they'd get me to do it again so what
point do you find out you're actually
under arrest and now going to prison
jail what where are we headed I remember
it so vividly it's January 4th 2005. I'm
sitting I'm uh working day watch or what
do we call it so you're still working
I'm still working Police Department okay
yeah I'm on you're not on suspension or
leave or any of that no because this
then you know because they want to catch
yes gotcha um when that happened I was
working morning watch I was working
overnights now I'm working uh afternoon
watches called morning watch afternoon
day one anyway I work 2 30 to P.M to 10
30 p.m so it's about 4 P.M January 4th
2005. I'm sitting there in a parking lot
of a strip mall eating Chinese food just
eating Chinese food in the car and
every officer has a radio number for
example I was 31-13 three meaning the
third precinct one meaning the first
shift and 13 meaning the beat I work so
31 anytime they said 31-13 that was me
31 13 go ahead
um and we had
uniform Patrol officers we had sergeants
lieutenants and a commander the
commander was in charge of the whole
Precinct he was the the highest ranking
officer at this Precinct above him you
only had uh Deputy Chief and chief so
this guy was a big wig I forgot his name
but he the the commanders and the
lieutenants would never get on the radio
you never heard them on the radio it was
always sergeants talking to the officers
officers talking to the 911 dispatch uh
in his his number was 3101 whenever
someone was an 0-1 that was a commander
that was oh [__]
and we had a regular channel on the
radio that everybody could hear if you
had a police scanner a civilian could
sit there and listen to it and then we
had a private Channel and that's on on
regular channel I might go 3113 switch
to private
and then you switch to private and now
we have a private conversation our other
officers can hear it but civilians can't
police scanners people can't hear it
uh 3101 to 3113 go to private you got an
01 to a 13 go to private you're having
Chinese food to park yeah and of course
everybody else is like
3113 is on private
3113 I forgot what the code was uh some
code to meet back at precinct I forgot
whatever signal or code that was but
31 13 10 4.
10 minute drive do you know what's up I
I assumed it had something to do you do
yeah it's like well because I had a
clear conscious other than that and like
I said even the suspensions like
I didn't feel guilty about wrecking a
car I didn't feel guilty about breaking
that guy's wrist right like I'm out here
trying to [__] do my job and not get
killed right so the only guilty
conscience I had the only thing I know
and I walk into the precinct and then
the Commander's office is the commander
Lieutenant two sergeants and two
detectives from internal affairs damn
and you know about Internal Affairs they
that's a cop that investigates other
cops so and I was just like [__] and
they're like come in and close the door
how y'all doing and like go ahead and
take your gun off they immediately asked
for my gun and gave my gun
and then they were like
I forgot how they I mean it was all just
a blur I forgot how they eased into the
conversation down or you standing
standing just shaking
and then they were like you know we got
a complaint from so and so so and so
like uh was that you I was like
yep
all right go with these two detectives
and the two Internal Affairs guys uh I
rode with them in their car they didn't
handcuff me then but I went to Internal
Affairs in like five hours of just that
classic
you know 48 hours they're trying to find
out if you're this serial offender and
you're targeting Latinos who don't speak
English who may be here illegally yeah
and they were convinced and they were
convinced that AI was doing that
serially and B I was with no proof of it
yeah with no proof of it yeah that's the
only that's I guarantee that's the only
complaint I got because honestly that's
the only time I ever did it but they
thought I was doing it habitually and
they thought I was working with other
cops and I remember one time they kept
saying just give us a name give us a
name and we'll we'll take it easy on you
and I remember saying this vividly and
the police world's weird and that like
do you not get to ask for an attorney
right then and there and not answer the
question you could have but I was just I
was like I know where this is headed I
knew I was guilty so I was like [__] it
whatever's gonna be and and part of me
was relieved because I [__] hated the
job
but um
police world is weird because let's say
you're my partner even if we don't get
along I don't like you you don't like me
at the end of the day there's a mutual
respect and camaraderie because we're we
have each other's lives in our hands
right and I had a couple of good friends
there but there was just a lot of guys I
just didn't get along with because they
were they were just stereotypical
[__] cops that's one thing that I
get so frustrated with police police are
granted an incredible amount of
discretion meaning
you know I they've given me the power
and the discretion to go to these calls
and make a decision and my point is
there's a lot of cops out there
including ones I worked with if legally
I can arrest you I'm going to no if ands
or but right where I not to Pat myself
on the back but I tried to use a little
common sense and discretion for example
you go to a a domestic dispute you know
and she says he did this and he says he
didn't and there's kids and you learn
the story that he's working and she's
out of work and now she's sitting there
with a black eye and a bust a nose sorry
buddy you're going to jail but if it's
there's no EV my point is
arresting this guy tonight is that the
best thing for this family if he goes to
jail and is out of work I got three kids
now like I said there's some crimes well
sorry buddy you're going to jail but
like the the iffy stuff
man tonight's your lucky night don't
maybe come back here but my point is
there's so many cops I worked with like
nope 10 15 was the code for arrest 10 15
10 15. regardless of any discretion I
don't know where it's going with that
part oh
oh yeah they said uh they were convinced
that I was that I had partners and I
remember them saying just give us a name
and I said look if there was a name I
could give you I would do it because I
I'm not loyal to any of these [__]
I was like if I was if I could give you
a name and and make my sentence lighter
I of course I'd do it but I'm telling
you for the tenth time it was a one-time
thing and nobody else was involved they
were just so convinced that I was part
of a ring of cops doing this and uh they
they said they were going to make an
example of me like shamed the department
you've shamed your community uh the
district attorney is going to make a
example out of you this is there's no
plea Bargains available this is going to
trial you will get convicted and you
will go to prison for three to five
years [__]
how do you feel yeah I used to you just
[__] like I need to sit down I mean
that was and this for six months from
the time they told me that to the time
it was all done it was about six or
seven months for six or seven months
that's like I'm going to prison in July
so wait you're allowed to go home yeah I
well I I they let me go that night yeah
they let me go that and I wasn't even
charged they were like you're probably
going to be charged in a week or two you
are as of this moment fired you're free
to go but once we get all our paperwork
and ducks in a row we will file a
promise yeah and I'm sure enough about
two and in between I did go get an
attorney and uh about two weeks later
the attorney called and said all right
they've officially filed charges you
need to go turn yourself in and that was
a rough day my mom and my girlfriend
drove me down to where Cobb County
correctional facility and uh I was in I
was in cry no no I was I was I felt like
it but I was there for about four or
five hours where uh in jail not prison
but jail like a cell yeah just a sale by
yourself no with about 10 other dudes
and as even then immediately I was like
boy I hope they don't find out I'm a cop
just in jail no prison's a whole another
story but yeah I was just in jail for
like five hours my girlfriend and Mom
bonded me out I forgot what my bond was
but they went to a bail bondsman you
know that whole routine paid ten percent
friends that are available yeah so so
then you're out and then you're out now
until your court date yeah which how
much time was that for you there was a
couple of different uh like arraignments
I think I went back to court two or
three times over the next six or seven
months but the whole time
I'm here at work no well I immediately
started a landscaping business okay so
uh actually the day I I was unemployed
for one day after that first day I went
home the next day it's just you know
telling my girlfriend telling my parents
everything and then the very next day I
went down to the unemployment office and
I was standing in line because you know
I had rent I had you know I have
standing lines just like my [__] this
you know I'm not I'm not and I uh I got
a job the next day driving a limo I
drove limos for like three months I
remember when that wasn't yeah
we had one of our clients was a hip-hop
label so I drove around Little John I
drove ludicrous I drove all these
rappers and I just remember thinking
like a week ago I was a cop now I'm
driving a limo and there's ludicrous in
the back so I did that for a few months
while I got my landscaping business off
the ground and uh you know this was like
I said I this happened in January so you
know in Georgia there's no Landscaping
to be done in the winter but so I slowly
I bought some equipment took out a loan
from my dad bought bought a trailer and
some equipment I had this nice little
landscaping business going and uh funny
people who know this band will will
appreciate this but uh the the guys that
were working with stuck Mojo and Fozzie
the main guy Jericho's the singer but
the founder of both those bands is a
guitar guy named Rich Ward and I was a
huge fan all through High School
whatever
um so and then you know this was before
cop stuff I was working for them but I
kind of kept in touch with Rich and uh
just ran into him like it blocked Buster
video right after all this happened and
he had been touring a lot but he had
taken a big break and he was like oh
you're doing landscaping he's like he's
like you need any help
I was like what he's like do you need
any part-time help I was like yeah but
Rich Ward you want to come Edge
sidewalks with me uh but anyway so rich
was my uh assistant for a few months and
my point is uh those six or seven months
between the arrest and and the trial uh
like I said
every week my attorney is like
prepare to go to prison for three years
and I was like
okay you're out there on a ride
so I had already uh Rich had agreed to
take I wanted I was going to keep the
business I was going to turn the
business over to Rich uh and then uh I
was gonna have him give we'd cut a deal
like hey you can take over this business
but uh let's take 25 percent of Revenue
and give it to my fiance while I'm in
prison for three years
and uh so yeah and just that was such a
surreal spring because I'm just riding
around cutting Lawns and you know
thinking about going to prison and oh by
the way my my metal hero
Sports over here weed whack to people
who know like he said yeah his picture
was on Guitar Center I mean this guy's
like a a guitar God and I'm like hey
Rich when you're done with the front can
you go weed eat the back and he's like
sure thing Dave
but Rich was going to take over my
business and give some of the revenue to
my fiancee that's nice for three years
while I was in prison that's nice all
right so then what happens
uh you're being you're preparing every
day your anxiety has got to be through
the roof I'm going to prison prison
prison what must that be like and if I
thought I'm a cop and I'm a cop if I
thought I was going to White Collar
prison that would have been you know
Troublesome of like uh what have I done
to my life yeah I'm going to prison not
as a cop but as a dirty cop dirty cop in
gen pop in gen pop [__] that what's up
white boy what's up remember me
[__]
nope theoretically could be in prison
with people I put that's what I'm saying
not in a different state the same right
same state same area going to prison for
three years is a dirty cop and I was
like well
I'm either gonna get murdered or raped
or I'm gonna have to murder somebody
from not getting raped so
probably gonna be a lot more than three
years
and it it was a horrible horrible spring
just thinking about that every day and
again nobody's fault but my own nobody's
fault but man it isn't a woe with me
nobody [__] made me take that but I
am Telling You sincerely it was not a
scam to to you know abuse vulnerable
immigrants I was just like it was a
split second of poor judgment and
Rebellion I was like
[__] y'all sure I'll take your [__]
50 bucks
and
yeah so like I said the whole time that
whole spring was just like and my
attorney was like there's no way around
it man they're pissed oh come on man I
just got a new Snapper ride the news I
was all over the news oh [__] all your
faces out there in the area that I grew
up in where you're cutting grass
people I went to high school people
recognize you like from leaning out like
this guy's cut my [__] grass
that I don't know but uh I know a lot of
people I grew up with were like oh [__]
that's Dave Stone
uh for about two weeks it was on the
local news every night every night what
are they saying what's the what's the
portrayal on the news is it the whole
dirty cops taking advantage of uh
immigrants yeah also they are putting
that narrative publicly yes and they set
up a hotline if you think you or someone
you know was a victim of Officer stone
called this number how many people are
calling that goddamn one I asked him
after the fact I said how many [__]
calls y'all get how many calls did you
get and they they tell you I was like
see [__] told you but yeah they set
up a hotline what days and had you
trailed and all that stuff yeah and by
my point is uh by some miracle
like the the 23rd hour What's The Phrase
the 23rd 25th hour right before like a
two a day or two before the trial my
attorney calls me is like I I don't know
what happened but they're swamped they
got a overloaded caseload they want to
do a plea bargain if you plead guilty to
this uh you'll stay out of prison you'll
do five years of probation
and I was like all right and I pled
guilty and what if you didn't then it
would have went to trial and if I would
would they have it would they have had
to admit though that they had no calls
on the hotline and all this yeah but I'm
not being charged for that like the
thing I'm being charged with is the
thing you actually did yeah and I
admitted to it you know off the Record
you said it yeah and you know looking
back I'm like you know should I have not
but I was just like like karmically and
cosmically I was like well I've already
done the bad deed let me at least try to
just be honest from here on out and
whatever I get I deserve all right so
you take the plea bargain you're guilty
what does that mean for you in the state
of Georgia and as far as are you a
convicted felon the rest of your life
can you vote can you carry a firearm
what happened at the time I was a
convicted felon even though I pled
guilty it's still a conviction and uh
five years probation uh once a month
just had to go and you know meet with
the probation officer and do what piss
test and all no they didn't they didn't
piss test me because it was wasn't drug
or alcohol related uh the main
stipulation like the bill what's your
test my stipulation is I'm not allowed
to work in law enforcement during the
probation period okay so every time
every month I'd go really the only
question he would ask me well he'd ask
me have I been arrested for anything
Petty or otherwise this month and am I
working as a law enforcement officer and
I was like no it was Landscaping just
landscaping and it started doing comedy
right after that that's a whole other
story but I wanted to start comedy when
I was 19 and uh just never had the nerve
I used to go to open mics I'd write
jokes go to Open Mic sign my name three
or four times I went they call my name
and I just didn't have the nervous just
in the back of the room silent and then
after all that I was like [__] it I'm
I'm doing I'm doing comedy so so you
can't work law enforcement can you vote
no couldn't vote couldn't carry a
firearm but that's just for the
probation period well technically yes
because an average felon in Most states
it's for Life For Life but I got first
offender status because I had a clean
record up until then I got some first
offender status program where uh what's
the term after probation it's supposed
to be expunged like disappear from my
record which it did not because years or
later I applied at uh to get an
apartment and one of the questions was
have you ever been convicted of crime
and I put no and then like they were
like hey we got a hit the here that says
you did why are you lying to us like
well to be honest with you I'm not lying
purposefully but I was told that it
disappears for my record and I didn't
have to admit that after the five years
and they're like well it showed up on
our search so how do you get that clear
uh I don't know I'm still working on
that really and I tried to buy uh ammo
at Walmart a few years ago this was you
know 18 years after the fact and
something popped something flagged and
they wouldn't sell it to me so I got to
get all that straightened out through
the state of Georgia but yeah it was
supposed to disappear for my record
after probation but and I don't give a
[__] about any of that really and I hear
you but you but I am allowed to vote for
some reason I have been voting but the 5
Firearms thing they're looking at that
being like throw it out yeah
what about
um okay so here's the thing that sucks
for you I think is that you you take the
plea bargain right well I understand why
but you have to admit guilt so then all
that [__] on the news that narrative
is looks true because this dirty cop
just said he did do it because it was
true yeah I did do that but not what
they were saying about this whole ring
of police or you were like the leader of
this group that was [__] yeah taken
advantage damn dude
facing three to five as a cop in the
same spot where you [__] put people
[__] that yeah man big time Big Time
[__] that
um all right I want to uh shift gears
because I want to talk about this other
story real fast about uh some trouble
you have with a fire I guess
all right long story short my dad passed
away in uh
June of 18. and uh real unexpectedly
and of course that sucked
um and I just started dating my now wife
we were on again off again a lot or
before that but I just kind of we just
kind of cleaned everything up and
started really settling down together
and my dad passes away and uh
had to cancel dates I was in Cincinnati
about to do go bananas and I got the
phone call I had to cancel that and uh
anyway uh her dad owned a nice little
cabin up in Lake Arrowhead California
and my girlfriend at the time she was
like listen just go up there for like a
week
you know just mourn grieve you know do
whatever you got to do it's you know
right there on the lake it's beautiful
and uh she she had to stay back in LA
and do some work but I was up there for
about five or six days by myself and it
coincided with my birthday the second to
last day I was up there was my birthday
so she shows up with a barbecue smoker a
nice uh Brinkman trash can smoker I'm a
big barbecue guy and uh so I was like oh
cool and I remember I invited Billy
Wayne Davis uh good buddy he came up and
hang out and we had some birthday pulled
pork I smoked a pork roast and I've done
this hundreds of times and the way I
usually do it is you know you smoke
whatever you're smoking and then
especially if you're if you're things
sitting on concrete or something
non-flammable I just leave the coals in
the smoker and over time over a few
hours they burn themselves out no harm
no foul rather than you know eventually
you got to scoop that [__] out and
dispose of it because you get too much
of it but this is a new smoker you know
there was no old Ash is in there so I
spent like 14 hours smoking this pork
roast pork shoulder and you know we ate
it and had a good time and then late
that night I was like I'm just gonna
leave leave the thing there and we left
the next morning and uh so and the irony
is uh I remember it was a Sunday morning
we spent like two hours I was up there
for like a week so you know I it had
been well used but we spent about two
hours cleaning the cabin leave it like
you found it you know Dad was nice
enough yeah you know clean the kitchen
clean the porch blah blah blah and I
left the smoker on the back porch and I
left the uh coals in it the ashes in it
and I had I'd done the math like I had
stopped smoking it at about eight
o'clock P.M the night before and we left
at noon the next day so this is we're
going on 16 hours that these coals have
been sitting in this smoker and I even
touched the coals and stuck my hand in
there and stuff to make and it's cool to
the touch 16 hours they've been sitting
there
we drive the two hours back to LA we're
literally pulling into our apartment and
she gets a phone call from the neighbor
and she's like what
it's on fire
[__] by the time we had left two
hours later it had disappeared it was on
the news
you're back on the news again back on
the news like they didn't die but it was
on something they're like this dirty cop
burned this house yeah yeah
burned it to the ground are you sure
it's the coals though
great question Ryan I don't think it was
the coals but the Riverside County fire
investigator said oh he's a smoker
smoker must have done it Musta this is
all I want to go home
August in the mountains of California
are we sure it's not a coincidental
electric fire we sure somebody didn't do
something exactly but uh cool to the
touch and be able to put your hand in
there there's nothing that should be
able to pop out of that yep and uh
her dad could not have been cooler
yeah like I hated this
for insurance man I was like
do you understand what I'm telling you
like
this is about the worst phone call he
could get other than like hey your
daughter fell off a boat yeah what and
he's chill with it
foreign
ER Insurance rebuilt bigger flipped it
sold it boom I think I inadvertently did
it myself
he has since passed but something was up
because he was too chill yeah like man
we got yeah I wonder if he didn't do it
and at the end of the conversation he
goes well I got one question I was like
what's that sir how was the barbecue
it's pretty good sir I don't know if
it's worth all the trouble but uh yeah
that was a good time damn dude yeah uh
well that's a great way to end the
episode right there brother
um thank you for coming on uh before we
end this officially uh it's your first
time here I'm gonna get ask you now
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self don't become a cop
ha
and watch your carbs
um plug and promote everything again
please uh pack a lunch uh now on YouTube
uh it's my first actual proper special
uh audio version you can find digitally
uh there might still be some vinyl left
at blondmedicine.com and uh boogie
monster every when do we release that
twos every Tuesday with me and Kyle
Kinane stoneberg's every Wednesday with
me and my wife Katie strandbergstone so
yeah all right come see me on tour dumb
davestone.com thank you and uh guys out
there support the special go watch it
come see me on tour tickets are
available Ryan sickler.com thank you as
always we'll talk to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign